we got this call came in right here uh
this one looks funny it says funny
teaching story let's go
my name is paige and i am a teacher in
seattle washington oh paige thank you
for calling i was just up in uh tacoma
last week and that's
uh cold water country you know it's hard
to get cold water out there
even in the bird bath you see birds stop
by check the water too [ __ ] cold
take off diet dehydration
you know a lot of that water just too
cold for animals even to
i caught a bass it was [ __ ] shivering
you know sometimes you'll catch a bass
or something and they
they just flopping on the counter you
know this one [ __ ] shivering
he had water on his body right and he
was bouncing on the wood on the
on the dock and he used the water on his
body just
bouncing bouncing bouncing bouncing
bouncing to spell out
hot cocoa he just h you know
boom boom boom h
and he did all that until he had no more
moisture on his body hot cocoa
i was like damn everything's cold out
here that's cold water country thank you
for calling paige onward
so you wanted to know like who's
watching your podcast and so
i do want to know that and i appreciate
it thank you for calling us here more
it's i'm a teacher a middle school
teacher and i watch a podcast
and oh you're a middle school teacher
huh that's amazing
a lot of middle school teachers out
there and that's beautiful man
especially when you got a beautiful
female teacher and you're a young boy
you show up
because you sound attractive paige you
know you sound attractive to me
and all you got to be is about a four or
up to be attracted to daddy you know
so you sound attractive to me and um
onward
something funny that happened the other
day and i was thinking about it when you
were talking about like being in middle
school and
just like how weird people are in middle
school but i
also coached volleyball and so i um
and i'm not supposed to be thinking
about i'm not thinking about that wasn't
um to middle
school volleyball that was just uh
you know when i think about like a like
kind of an attractive teacher teaching
volleyball that thing kind of why
you know that thing gets me you know
makes me flare a little
you know make my make my loins turn into
lions
and that's really just all you gotta do
is switch a letter you know that
i turn my loins in a lion's boy yeah
i change at school and so i was changing
my classroom from volleyball
okay you're changing let's go back a
second here we go i'm gonna shut up
well and so i was changing my classroom
let's get back a little more here we go
school and just like how weird people
are in middle school but
i also coach volleyball and so i change
at school
and so i was changing my classroom for
volleyball
man i don't know if i'm being a pervert
or if i'm just being just regular
you know in los angeles you're not
allowed to uh have any interest in women
anymore
so you know i feel like what we're doing
right now is very it's like almost like
prohibition
but that i'm secretly having to do this
in a studio somewhere on the third floor
of a building onward
and i just like left all my clothes on
like near my desk
and i obviously like changed into a
sports bra and so
i like to have oh man like i don't
you ever have like one of your fantasies
you feel like it just called a telephone
number that's what i feel like right now
i mean this is this is something you
know this is a middle school
teacher telling me she just changed in
her classroom and you got me
you know you got my wiener starting to
loiter around you know
around my waistline you feel me onward i
have to take off my bra
and i gotta hear that part again sorry
changed into a sports bra
and so i have to take off my bra and so
my
like bra and all my clothes are like
sitting there and
um the next day but you couldn't see the
bra so
the next day the kids came in they said
i knew you lived here i knew you lived
here you have all your clothes here you
have a suitcase here and like i have to
keep my suitcase at school because it
doesn't fit in my apartment because i
live in seattle
and so i was like you know what and i'm
like grabbing my clothes and i'm putting
it in this bag i'm like come out of your
business
and out falls my bra
onto the ground and there was two eighth
grade boys and one of them
ran for the door he they both went
and ran oh he probably went to
masturbate i'm guessing
i mean i couldn't imagine that you know
and i'm not trying you know
and i know you're probably thinking he
went for something else but
at eighth grade if an attractive teacher
dropped a bra in front of me
what i would be like dude i would
probably be
i'd be i'd turn into louie ck boy
i'd start wine gardening those plants or
whatever harvey weinsteiner
i'd hit those plants and just start
weinsteining you know what i'm saying i
put a
you know i'd put a pearl necklace on a
cactus if you had a [ __ ] cactus in
the window
onward and the other boy he just stood
there staring at it and i
jumped on it like it was a grenade
covering it up and i was like
oh god a hot teacher jumping on her bra
in the classroom
i mean this is paige thank you so much i
got to hear i'm going to play this again
later in the car but i want to hear it
again uh let's hear
a little more thank you paige get out of
here get out of here
and so they ran out of the classroom but
you know it's tough out here and
also i'm coming to your show with my
best friend taylor this weekend
and in tacoma and we're so excited to
see you
oh i didn't even realize paige i thought
that was from this week um thank you
thank you for calling i thank you so
much um
and i hope you and taylor had a nice
time wow that's a sexy story though
i just heard this a sexy story you know
and
shout out to the kid who stayed around
that eighth grader that's a g
right there that boy sees that brawl hit
the ground
the one dude he's out that dude ain't
gonna get laid until probably late into
college
but that eighth grade boy he's thinking
man
you know maybe we playing strip poker
without the cards
you know and and and miss page went
first
oh man you make me want to go back to
middle school
man you make me wish i couldn't really
read and spell that well
you know and you know i just you know i
could do some algebra but barely
said i could go back to middle school
and just apply myself
to some fine teachers you know
thank you for calling paige that's
that's a that's everything
did i remember i'm trying to think of
the hot
i mean first of all i remember as a kid
in middle school i was attracted to any
teacher
you know even if it was like a male
teacher with real long hair who
conditioned his hair
if that dude turned around to face the
board and he had a nice ass boy i'd
think about him
you know i mean i had feminine wilds but
if he came across as a as feminine into
my eyes
boom then that just projected right into
my brain
because you and all you had to do was
think about something
and your dick would start looking for
somebody remember that
you know i never owned a pet growing up
really outside of you know small ground
game
um but man having a penis when you're
young
it's like having a pet it's like having
a you know
it's like having a you know it's like
having a runt
fee a runt ferret that has attention
deficit disorder
you know your dick can start looking
around you know it's a down everything
it's just
your dick is just white
you know your dick will eat a piece of
you know your dick
will eat a corn kernel i bet your dick
has so much
you know relativity at that point when
you're young
your penis got that vibe boy your penis
just show
up i mean
your penis will provide services you're
reading a book you don't have a um
a book stopper a word remember piece of
paper
bam your dick shows up i got you dog
you know when you're young your penis is
violent
it's vibrant you know your penis looking
for things to do
i bet man i bet there's gotta be a video
out there somebody taught their penis to
eat a piece of corn
and if you have that video send that in
man i'm not gonna you know
i'll probably i'm not gonna watch it
more than one time
you know but i will watch it for you
know the artisticness of it in the
you know hashtag vegetarian
but yeah man those you know that was
young and i pre you know i remember i
remember huda
oh man we had this teacher i think her
name was like miss baldwin or miss
boudreau or somebody
i think i was in seventh or eighth grade
and she had perfume or like perfume and
she had
i mean she just looked like
i i every boy i know can't do math
from my hometown and it's because of her
it's her fault dude i wanted to get
problems wrong so i could stand there
and just
smell her while she like showed me the
work
she's like you got to show your work and
i'm just like i can't think cause
sixty percent of the blood is in my
penis and nuts while i'm sitting there
listening to her
you know i couldn't even bend my legs
that's how erect i was
you know i had to roll over to her desk
and then you know pull myself
up by my arms and those were just i mean
miss bowder what was her name
miss vaughn so i don't know she just i
remember
here's how sexy she was i remember she
wore red
that's all i remember she might have
never worn red
but i that's just what i rem she but red
is that color of sex of lust it's just
like in my brain she wore red
she had dark hair and like
you know all of my youthful masturbation
and probably a lot of my young erections
i
you know i you know i would attribute to
her probably or
you know if i could leave something my
will
it would be for her you know it'd be for
her to get
you know maybe now in her life i don't
know if she has a man now or whatever
but
you know a lot of women as they get a
little bit older they still want to
catch some you know
you know some routine cop you know some
hard d
and i was young back then but you know
uh
my dick had an old soul i always felt
like that and my dick had seen things my
dick had seen railroads being built
you know my dick had heard like a you
know like a printing press in the
distance my dick had seen
i had an old soul i had an old soul dick
and if i could leave something in a will
or something i would leave
a lot of those old directions of my past
to her good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watch this one